aren't you guys almost at the point now
where you can fly privately or do you
not want to be that insulated yes the
problem is I think airplanes as a whole
are so wasteful and are really really
affecting the world in a not a great way
and the problem is that I have a job
where I simply can't not fly like I
would love to not fly and to travel in a
net more you go more greenway right um
but the problem is that I can't
and so we are like right now like trying
to find ways of what there's like a
thing you can do I think where you like
yeah there's some kind of an exchange
like an exchange you do I think we're
working on it I don't know but because I
can't do it I do a lot more a lot of
other things be to try to make up for it
but private jets like I I want to so bad
right and I probably will I don't know I
will I fully will 100% I will but it's
just like I hope that by the time I I do
there's like a way more green way to do
it
it is said I mean that we are pissing
all over the planet I really I know and
we're way behind in trying to clean this
thing up